[Musique]
Carole Denver l'enfant prodige de la
Voie Lactée
[Musique]
tu m'as tout pris
maintenant c'est toi qui va tout perdre
qu'est-ce qui m'arrive
elle a entremêlé nos pouvoirs c'est
qu'on s'en sert on prend la place l'une
de l'autre
toi tu absorbes la lumière
moi je la détecte et kanala
le pouvoir de changer la lumière en
matière et ça j'en avais jamais entendu
parler mais vous montrer si vous voulez
[Musique]
elle a pris toutes nos planètes pour
cibler
je ne veux entraîner personne dans cette
guerre
tu n'es pas toute seule à pouvoir
protéger l'univers
[Musique]
plus loin
plus vite
[Musique]
c'est qui le gentil chat son papa un
gosse
non là c'est trop tu veux bien
[Musique]